so what was the question there was there
a question
as a twelve-year-old kid I'm sitting
there playing with my toy cars I saw
this incredible movie and I wanted a toy
tucker and I bought this little Tucker
model when I finally did well in my
business not only did I end up with a
Tucker but I ended up with Tucker's
Tucker and it's been our pleasure and
privilege to preserve this car Preston
Tucker was kind of a hero because you
know here was a guy who had a great idea
and you know I think he was a little
ambitious and but he was the American
Dream encapsulated this car was kind of
a game changer in the automotive
industry and it set the stage for
innovations that are still innovative
today you know the the turning headlight
in the center was something that modern
cars came up with in the 80s but Preston
Tucker was doing this in the 40s he got
almost all the way there you know he was
a few months away from from putting out
hundreds of cars a day but all that's
left of his dream r-47 survivor
prototypes that made it out all right
this is the the jewel of your collection
the 1948 Tucker this is a guy that
actually did it he's a car enthusiast
that said I'm gonna make a car and found
a way to make it happen he made 50
prototypes and then was shut down but he
was ready to turn that line on padded
dashboard and pop out windshield I mean
these were Tucker first in 1948 that you
know it took till the 80s in some cases
to get on in modern cars it's this
interesting motor it's an aircraft motor
it smokes a little bit on startup but
you know the Tucker had a lot of power
in its day so Matt just like that famous
picture that we've got a Preston Tucker
sitting in his car waving out to the
public I got to get you in the front
seat of this one and have you waved so
Erik the next time you take this car out
be sure to call me I'm definitely going
for a ride it's not every day that you
get to sit into a Tucker this has been
so much fun now
you have this great car collection let's
go for a ride in something pick up
something that you think is gonna be fun
all right I'm gonna hook you up with a
real chick magnet all right let's go
really this is the best you've got
you're gonna love it come on it's so
tiny wow it's fast 28 horsepower I hope
you've enjoyed this continue look at
Eric Brussels private collection
including an amazing 1948 Tucker now
please subscribe at GQ calm and see more
episodes of car collectors